yeah he's going to throw a lot of those
he's seemingly increased that number
over his last couple starts
he's getting swing a lot of swings and
misses especially against lefties
41 strikeouts and 38 and two-thirds for
zach wheeler
ground ball off the hands over to third
gobbled up by bone
and an easy first inning for zach
wheeler
the big wove brandon woodruff no
decision his last time out against the
dodgers six innings six has two runs
having a difficult time landing anything
right now a couple of change-ups miss
and here's a site that we absolutely
don't want to see
scott barringer the athletic trainer
out to take a look at brandon woodruff
woodruff says he's all right no surprise
there
the phillies have two on for reese
hoskins
here comes the one-two got him first
strikeout first out recorded here for
woodruff yeah the off-speed's been good
for woody
0-2 pitch struck him out swinging with a
high fastball
97 up above the belt
goes after the first pitch here and
lifts it into center field
jackie bradley jr puts it away and
woodruff battles back two early walks
then two strikeouts and a fly ball and
we are through one
three-two pitch to shaw grounded out to
second base
and mate tom to a knee throws him out
got him threw him with slider picked up
his first strikeout
and they're two outs here at the top of
the second
got him threw him a slider and it was
wicked back-to-back strikeouts
at six up six down for zach wheeler in
the first couple of minutes
ahead of andrew nappa ball two strikes
knapp leading off here in the second
inning
and a pack and a high fastball and their
strikeout number
three for brandon woodruff and awesome
there's a change-up
swing and a miss by mayton another
strikeout that's number four
woodruff looking to put away his
counterpart and he does with a strikeout
so
a hip but three strikeouts
you're not comfortable that you get the
quick answer here's billy mckinney
that's a fair ball
down the line in right field brad miller
will run it down mckinney on his way to
second the brewers have their first hit
of the game
so rudder in scoring position for melee
melee hitting 231 he's one for seven in
the series
off the hands over to first caught out
of the air i think by reece they're
gonna double up mckinney
two outs here in the third
yeah he got it she did beautiful
swing and a miss and that certainly
cleaned up the inning for the phillies
three strikeouts for wheeler
the ball two strikes to brad miller and
a swing and a miss
will blow by at 97 and that's six
strikeouts now for woodruff
0-2 pitch and swing at a miss nasty
breaking ball
maybe we'll secure it and brandon
woodruff
who's one two three in the philadelphia
phillies and we are
through three and some good pitching
going on
wong buns one toward third one hop for
bowm
and a good pick by hoskins and one quick
out here in the fourth
two two pitch here's a swing of the
ground ball past the bound dede
to the left of second has it he's got
time he'll throw the first and
we'll go back is retired
ground ball to shortstop gregorius waits
on it sets his feet
and three roundouts and wheeler has
another easy inning he's threw
four so far he's allowed one hit
glorious sends one over to daniel vogel
back
unassisted for the big man look at the
all-star games you have to remember they
played two back then
one-two pitch and this is lined right
into the glove of vogelback who squeezes
it for the out
one-two pitch to nap and the high
fastball results in strikeout number
eight
zach wheeler will face travis shaw he's
allowed one hit that was a double to
billy mckinney
as that balls popped up outside of home
plate and andrew that makes the sliding
basket grab
see how he goes over and gets the best
of cats you know it's gonna
go into your mitt
swing and a miss threw him a backup
slider
here's urias who's old for one he struck
out his first time pops that one up
into right here comes may todd he'll get
there makes the catch
both starters living up to the
reputation
there's so far on this thursday
afternoon
struck him out with a high fastball
brandon woodruff
wins the battle on the 11th pitch of the
at-bat
nick maton strikes out swinging
there's herrera with a liner into right
and tyrone
taylor runs it down and lets out a
little woo
in the process nice catch taking extra
bases away from herrera
mega 10. as he fans zach wheeler
wheeler's only allowed the double to
billy mckinney he's faced the minimum
and a called strike three he thought it
was ball four but the slider got on the
inside part of the plate
five strikeouts for wheeler a 1-1
swinging a broken back ground ball left
side boom backed up a second now charges
scoops it throws on the run the barrel
of the bat ends up out by
shortstop one two pitch coming
and a call strike three six strikeouts
for wheeler
starting a little funky is going into
shut down mode
and ten punch-outs the 2-2 came right
back with it struck him out swinging
strikeout number 11 walking a strikeout
and right back to woodruff
[Applause]
two men out
[Applause]
bouncer over to luis urias
another one two three inning 13 in a row
now woodruff has retired the pitching
duel
continues for zach wheeler he's retired
the last 11
a swing and a miss he struck him out
fastball
just above the knees at 99. number seven
on a couple hops out to shallow right
field local back doesn't run well
try to finish off the brewers here in
the top of the seventh and he does
swing and a miss he got it with a curve
ball eight strikeouts for wheeler
he is dealing this afternoon he's faced
the minimum through
70s woodruff has not allowed a base
runner since the second inning
2-2 pitch gregorius fly ball center
field
this is playable for jackie bradley jr
comes in and makes the catch with the
sunglasses on
one ball of no strikes alec today has
popped out the center he's also lined
out
in the air right center field pretty
deep going back as taylor it
is gone opposite field home run for alec
the phillies have taken the lead he took
the 100th pitch from woodruff
and put it into the seats in right
center field
his fourth home run of the year is one
zip phills
heck of a day's work for woody six and
two thirds but he will exit
zach wheeler with a lead start the
eighth inning it's one to nothing
phillies
ground ball right side natan backhands
throws bradley out then he lines one to
short picked on one hot by gregorius
gets his bearings throws low to first
dug out
by rhys hoskins the inning is over well
here's reese hoskins he's got a chance
to open up some breathing room
and a lighter down the left field line
toward the corner that is a fair ball it
kicks up some dust
score miller to third rbi double for
reese hoskins
two nothing phillies zach wheeler
goes after the complete game shutout
little looper out to left field here
comes mccutchen he's there as he leaps
at the last
moment to make the catch so now two on
and the top of the order in colton wong
[Music]
fly ball left field playable for
mccutchen he says he has it
eyes are on it makes the catch two outs
daniel vogelback
tying run is it first base for the
brewers
in the air to right field it's not deep
long run for everybody foul territory
hoskins is there
makes the catch and the ball game is
over
a complete game shutout for zach wheeler